ah
[Aplausos]
pero
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ahora
[Música]
no
[Aplausos]
no necesito
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
[Aplausos]
no
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la verdad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mamá está viva
[Música]
todo
este chico vino
[Música]
qué
en la mente
[Música]
el país
lecce picazón
as
y
[Música]
as
i
tu piel
[Música]
con solo
menos
[Música]
mi vida
wow
[Música]
y
dicha
[Música]
bueno a veces discutimos un
baile
[Música]
spacey
todos
[Música]
para nubes
y
[Música]
detrás mío
hoy
[Música]
t
y españa spain
dorantes
sí no
[Música]
y
ah
[Música]
a la misma nena interior
con poca ayudarte
hamza creo
dios perdona
[Música]
gracias por perdonarme
lástima
gracias para estimar mal
si gas libra batida nena ahora
asegura
el mejor
todo está bien todo está bien
hasta valorar este canto
ok santi al teódulo
todo está bien
todas también
es hora de sanar
y del castor niza estimado
ah
a la miga veo
[Música]
no dejes cats y lanzini
las temas para aulas son dignas
no tengo
expresa la teva varita de amor
lynch mil ya total canasta citó
conectó al meter amarme o por
ciento a casa
una tocó cuando acarició todo pasaba
entra me
comprometo sé vulnerable
y hablantes
tijuana control
y torno a mí
moreau perdidos
una víbora
y su poderosa shock suficiente
sombras llosa
shock
y